just work just quick PC gaming is
getting way too expensive and if there's
a way that we can bring the price down
then I think we should be talking about
it and something that we covered a few
months ago was this machine here it was
actually powered by Intel's Arc GPU
something that had a lot of hike but
launched to a little bit of a well from
honest a little bit of a fart smell it
was not particularly well received but
you know what things have actually
changed there's been quite a few updates
for this that's not only give you quite
a lot more performance but hopefully
will improve the usability and I wanted
to take this opportunity to actually
give you my full experience with Intel
Arc go through some of the pros but also
some of the cons and yes there are
definitely quite a few to ultimately
help you answer the question that if you
are after a more budget-friendly gaming
computer is Intel Arc actually a solid
option we'll be revealing
I'm only joking it's already in the
computer oh I'm so funny aren't I but I
know absolutely everything you need to
know about Arc and whether you should be
buying one after a short word on this
video sponsor elgato's stream deck plus
is here and it takes your gaming setup
to a whole new level control lights
volume color balance stream settings and
a whole lot more with eight programmable
LCD buttons four clickable dials and
even an LCD touch bar it can be as
simple as a swap between headset and
speakers or controlling an entire
streaming setup with just a single press
learn more today with the link down
below so okay here's a quick refresher
essentially Intel Arc is Intel's
graphics card and it's meant to compete
really with the likes of the Nvidia 3060
and 3070 performance is going to be
somewhere in between those two but the
whole idea was that the price of this
was meant to be lower and it would be a
much more enticing option what we've
essentially ended up with is a graphics
card that will probably run a little bit
hotter and we'll use a little bit more
power consumption than some of the rich
competition but again the price should
be lower however when you actually look
at the current market of gpus at the
moment I I honestly don't understand
what's going on with Intel it's almost
as if they're not really making that
many of these but I'm sure they are
because there's just not much
availability here in the UK at all and
the pricing of this is around about
350-ish pounds or the one step down from
this the a750 is around about 300 but
that's still pretty much the same really
as the competition from Nvidia and AMD
so unless we see a pricing drop of this
very soon already it's fighting an
uphill battle and here's the thing right
when I actually installed this inside
this rig and it is a beautiful rig if
you haven't already seen the video
please go check out the top ranked
corner of your screen it was sponsored
by ASRock when we made this absolutely
beautiful PC but immediately we had some
issues because as soon as I tried to
install the driver it was actually
hanging it wasn't doing it properly it
did actually install the driver but it
didn't do something that it was supposed
to and it just sort of in infinitely
hung and I just had to hope for the best
really and to be fair it did seem as if
the driver was installed but it
definitely wasn't a very good user
experience and this is just a small
example of the sort of issues that
you're likely to experience if you do go
for an arc GPU because again while the
performance can be fine and we'll show
you this a little bit later don't you
worry it's just the software experience
is definitely lacking so just to
demonstrate if I press alt and I it does
bring up the like Intel Arc control unit
if you like and you've got a few
different options so here you can
download your drivers and get something
that's up to date except it currently
says updating your experience well it
said this for several hours and I've
restarted the PC several times and I
know I have the latest driver because I
downloaded it from their website great
you've got almost like an Nvidia Style
game Library so you can optimize
everything choose your settings and
things so let's say OverWatch would come
here and you can see some of the
settings will come up except that
they're not actually the settings for
the game they're just overriding
settings that you can put in through
Intel what and why why can't you do the
game settings as well it's
diffusing there is also this performance
tab so you can see everything that's
going on in real time you can even do a
little bit of performance tuning and
overclocking which can work to be fair
you've got this in-game overlay you can
turn on that works but sometimes it
affects your FPS more than it should and
then my personal favorite you've got
Studio that you can use to actually
broadcast capture and do all of your
highlights which for me is a massive
thing and I use it all the time on the
AMD cards and on Nvidia cards to record
these videos and this also has an av1
code inside it which means you can
actually use better quality streams and
better quality recordings from a lower
bitrate which is great but usually it's
got quite a high overhead on the CPU
which is why you have the hardware
encoder on the cart but the thing is not
only is it not enabled by default you
have to go into advanced settings here
and you have to choose it I know that's
broadcast here we go look capture
configure there we go and here you can
choose av1 AVC and agvc fantastic but
when I actually turn this on and hit
record it doesn't do anything it just
generates a file that's 300 bytes it
doesn't tell you it's not working it
just puts them all in one folder as well
and calls it out it's just just here's
the thing right as you can tell I'm
getting a little bit frustrating and I
haven't even spoken about performance or
anything like that pricing value it's
just a thing for me right is that PC
gaming used to be very very complicated
but over the years it's got to the point
where it really should be a case of just
plugging it in install the driver and
everything works and while there's
plenty of arguments out there about
who's got the better drivers between AMD
and Nvidia honestly both of them are
basically the same at this point there
are differences but both of them work
very very well they've tried very hard
to make it as user-friendly as possible
but with this it's like stepping back in
time 10 15 years the drivers don't
install properly when they do you have
to deal with this and it's just so Half
Baked from a company that has actually
been producing Graphics drivers for ages
because of course they've got Intel
integrated graphics and it's just really
frustrating so even if you can get a
brilliant deal you are going to have the
to deal with all of this and it's very
frustrating if you're wondering by the
way how I've actually been recording the
things you've just seen it's been with
OBS there's actually a hardware encoder
that you can tap into with the software
and in my experience this has actually
worked fine and if you look at the
overheads as well it seems to be using
the graphics card properly the CPU
barely moves and all in all when it
works it works are you serious it
doesn't even tell me the FPS I swear it
used to am I going mad I swear it used
to tell me the FPS so I've got my
performance Telemetry up here but it
doesn't work with frame view which is
what I usually use to monitor FPS so
last time I used Arc I did need to have
this extra menu up but quite wide frame
rate's not on here I I don't know you'd
think that's the main thing people want
in their inbuilt performance Telemetry
right but what you're seeing here is
cyberpunk 2077 this is running at 1080p
at the high preset I have turned off FSR
because I really don't like that at
1080p so you can get extra FPS if you
want but fascinated believe in that at
the moment but taking absolutely
everything else aside there's no doubt
about it that this is a very playable
experience I mean 350 pounds is pretty
much the cost of an Xbox though so 1080p
is not exactly high performance but
we're clearly getting probably about 50
to 60 FPS actually I'll get a frame rate
counter in just a second but it
certainly feels okay there's no doubt
about that I mean what happens if we do
turn it up to 1440p which to be fair is
what this card is actually marketed at
um well we definitely dropped there was
a bug earlier on when some games
actually performed better in 1440p than
1080 which was really weird we've
dropped now to about 40 to 45 FPS I'd
say just based on the feeling so it's
definitely very playable but again for
the money I wouldn't say that the value
is necessarily here in cyberpunk and
remember this is without any Ray tracing
enabled or anything like that in fact if
we do want to try a little bit of Ray
tracing we can go into the options menu
turn on
super resolution now because it's okay
at 144 GP but crucially we turn the ray
tracing on and I played this game before
with just the Shadows on nothing else
and
we've definitely lost a bit of FBS we're
now probably about 30 to 35 frames a
second so this is definitely at the
limitations if you like of the arc GPU
whereas if you were playing this on an
Nvidia card so something like a 3060 I
would argue that 1080p full Ray tracing
dlss is going to be very attainable So
Not only would you be getting a bit of
software experience there but in the
specific Nvidia titles if you like I
think you are just going to have a much
better overall experience oh hang on a
minute hang on a minute good guy Reddit
someone has given me a brilliant
suggestion look we can use the Xbox game
bar there we go was I right our FPS is
actually around about 52 52 FPS with Ray
tracing so there you go so the question
now though is is that higher than it was
a second ago because we were just
recording and I've stopped that so if we
now start recording
in OBS go back inside the punk locate no
it actually does seem to be about the
same actually still around about 47 to
50 FPS or so goes to show I was actually
underestimating clearly I'm used to high
refresh rate monitors so yeah around
about 47 FPS 1440p with some Ray tracing
that's not actually too bad is it again
I still think you'd have a better
experience if you like on 30 60. that is
better than I thought it would be I'm
actually slightly impressed what was it
without Ray tracing 1440p not
dramatically different actually about
five to ten FPS more so yeah maybe you
will want to try a little bit of Ray
tracing but there was only the Shadows
so it's not like the image quality is
going to be drastically different but
okay 1440p 60fps High settings and
cyberpunk
not too bad let's jump into our next
title though some war zone 2 and when I
tested the original War Zone on this PC
this was one of the quirkiest games I
think I tested because it didn't really
seem to change depending on the
resolution or settings or anything and
we were just getting a lot lower FPS
than I would have expected but I'm using
this as a bit more of a test to see
whether we can actually drive this
monitor which is 4K but use the new
Intel xcss technology so this is set to
the lowest possible render for 4K which
is the performance and in terms of frame
rate oh it doesn't actually say what
we're getting that's a bit annoying
just says loading
oh but this actually feels pretty good I
would wager we're probably looking at
about 80 to 90 FPS here which bear in
mind we are upscaling to 4K is actually
fairly impressive again I think what we
saw before was around about 80 to 100
FPS in Warzone one but now this is a lot
more optimized we should see over the
100 FPS Mark which is what most people
are going to be after really in a
multiplayer title oh performance tabs
not working now for goodness sake oh and
frameview doesn't work either it's just
a nightmare come on come on why when
this is the Moment of Truth isn't it can
I actually help out my teammate no
but I'm trying to bring in salt out
getting a FPS thing on screen
honestly why did I why do I start these
things but I mean this is exactly the
sort of thing that I'm talking about why
can't it just work out of the box be so
simple just press a button FPS comes up
you don't have to do all these
workarounds and then find that the
workarounds themselves don't work
properly
oh
honestly I've just spent what 40 45
minutes trying to get a frame rate
counter to work restarting the PC was
the best option uh MSI afterburner Riva
statistics none of that was working
either at all Nvidia frame view wasn't
working even though I looked up but it
worked for me a little bit before
honestly I'm getting frustrating but yes
here we go and this is 4K performance X
ESS and this is running actually at
quite High settings so I would say 60
FPS isn't too bad but we are seeing a
little bit of dropping so it's not a
surprise is it that this card can't
handle 4K resolution even though it's
sort of faux 4K resolution right but I
did want to encode this in there just to
sort of show you the limitations if you
like of the GPU as well as to actually
compare against some of the higher
resolutions so yes about 50 to 60 FPS 4k
xcss on performance but we are getting
some weird artifacting as well
could just be the game let's give it the
benefit of the doubt shall we okay 1440p
xcss set to Performance modes so the
game actually looks quite good I think
xcss does a very good job brilliant just
as we get uh mode down but yes 80 frames
a second is that enough from what is set
to Performance mode when it comes to
xcss I know we can turn some of the
settings down and it is still a good
frame rate I don't think there are too
many people out there that would
complain about 90 frames a second or so
but it's not necessarily as high as I
would like if you're buying a brand new
graphics card in 2023 that costs around
about what 350 pounds I don't know let
me know down in the comment section
below what you think and now I'm looking
back at the recording I can see the
frame rate counter doesn't appear on the
recording I'm going insane here guys I'm
going insane right we've restarted it
again and this time we're going to play
some Apex Legends and for whatever
reason Nvidia frame view seems to be
playing ball so you might actually get
to see the frame rate for once
unbelievable techers thank you but once
again we are now jumping out of a plane
but this time is of course Apex Legends
and this is running at 4K at just under
Max settings and suddenly the frame rate
is blowing my mind I know this isn't the
highest we've ever seen but still around
about 75 FPS at 4K from a card that's
not really supposed to be playing 4K it
really isn't too shabby at all Now isn't
it this is an incredibly impressive
experience actually and not one that I
expected I mean it depends what you play
right but clearly if you're going to be
playing something that is a bit more of
a lighter title something has good
compatibility I have to admit I thought
we were going to get less than this
bearing in mind that all of the tests
that we've done so far have other been
boosted with xcss or of course been a
little bit lower because we've got Ray
tracing and things on with cyberpunk not
too bad I mean we're actually now
getting 100 FPS 100 FPS at 4K so maybe
if you're a die-hard Apex Legends player
then it is worth considering an arc GPU
let's turn this down to 1440p now shall
we and see what difference that makes
actually not a massive one we are
getting slightly higher FPS and it is
going to be a whole lot more consistent
but it's nothing I would say is
particularly crazy what you'd normally
see is completely different FPS figures
at all of the different resolutions but
we don't actually see it that often it
doesn't line up with Nvidia and AMD when
it comes to the performance differences
at different resolutions which I don't
know if that means maybe it outperforms
at higher ones or whether it's just
underperforming at lower or maybe it's a
bit of both it's certainly peaking my
curiosity but regardless if you want to
play Apex Legends that's your game then
actually I can safely say handle heart
that's an arc GPU is a very good option
assume you can get it for the right
price are you actually serious it hasn't
recorded it with the overlay which was
the whole point of frame view I know
it's so Niche I know it's so Niche but
but honestly I have not been more
frustrated testing a system or testing
gpus than I have with Arc I mean at
least the story at the end of the day is
that you can get the gaming performance
out of it that you want it but it's just
the software the software lets it down
so much that you're just gonna be left
frustrated a lot of the time and and
it's just for a product that costs about
400 pounds 350 whatever it is that you
get it for it's just so deflating oh
goodness sake one more game one more
game and now frame view is not showing
up at all
foreign
however despite the lack of a frame rate
counter honestly I don't think I need it
because I think if this isn't 120 FPS I
will eat my hair and I know I've said
that before and you guys have commented
that you never see me in a hat so maybe
I don't have one but I assure you I've
got quite the collection the game looks
and feels incredible this is 1440p
running with xcss and I think xcss
actually is a very impressive technology
it seems to not be buggy from what I can
tell maybe it was at launch but here it
seems to be working without a hitch and
I would argue this looks very close to
4K resolution yeah it's not as I say
it's not even 1440p right it's upscale
to 1440p so it does do a good job when
it gets it right I just wish it got it
right more often and you know for me not
being able to hook a frame rate counter
in very easily is clearly a bit more of
an issue than it is going to be for you
guys but it's still going to be annoying
people want to know how their game
performs and if you can't get things to
run properly it is going going to be a
pretty frustrating experience but I'm
actually Keen to see what happens now if
we turn Ray tracing on I mean here are
your settings like 1440p while recording
remember with av1 xcss it to Quality so
actually that's why it looks so good
because it's set to high quality
so let's have a look if we go Ray traced
Reflections will this be at the end of
it well the only options are high or
very high actually so let's just leave
it a high and run again and see what
happens well the frame rate has
decreased by quite some margin actually
it's it now feels slow you know which
isn't what you want flying across the
rooftops in Spider-Man so you could play
like this but you can definitely feel
the increased latency this is something
Nvidia talk about all of the time now
but it is actually really important
because while I wouldn't say it looks
drastically different and what you're
seeing is obviously 30 frames a second
so it's not going to look drastically
different but
it's just not the way I would want to
have this game feel really so I think
this is what I said actually in the
previous video like while this card can
run Ray tracing I don't think the ray
tracing is necessarily fast enough for
you to turn it on a lot of the time I'm
interested to see what happens next time
around with Intel gpus but I think they
have to handle their launch and handle
their software and drivers better than
they are at the moment because as you
can tell this has been a pretty um
mediocre experience shall we say whilst
you definitely can extract all the
performance out of this I don't think I
would be happy with an arc GPU that's
the truth of it I mean if I could buy
this card for like 200 quid yeah that
that would be worth it but unless we see
a drastic price drop we see availability
increase a lot and that we see more
consistent performance across a range of
games and a range of resolutions because
while something like Spider-Man clearly
runs fantastically well on Arc as we saw
earlier it not the case with everything
and it's just quite unpredictable which
is something I thought would have
changed since the last driver update and
while things have definitely improved
we're not quite at the stage where I
think it's very easy to recommend but
next time there's a driver update I
guess we'll cover it again and maybe we
should do like a full budget GPU
Showdown where we actually compare all
of the arc gpus to I guess their
competition in much much greater detail
and we can give you the value
proposition so you can decide what's the
best option for yourself but love to
hear your thoughts on Ark is this the
sort of card that you think is going to
change things in the future for AMD and
Nvidia and make it more difficult or is
it a little bit too little too late I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this smash
the like button if you've enjoyed this
video get yourself subscribes and why
not grab yourself a PC Centric Mouse
mats link to this and everything
included in this PC is in the
description down below and while you're
down there why not grab the brand new
Elgato string deck plus this awesome
Gadget makes your life so much easier
with customizable controls for pretty
much any aspect of your gaming setup I
use mine to control Philips Hue nanoleaf
Elgato studio lights PC lighting and
much much more learn what you can do
with a stream deck plus today with the
link down below and thank you so much
for watching this video I'll catch you
in the next one
[Music]